What do you recommend as the top healing strategies for severe rheumatoid arthritis?
So well rheumatoid arthritis is an autoimmune disease so you have to dig in
to find out what the triggers are. Are there food triggers? Typically the food triggers
pretty much cross the board with auto with rheumatoid arthritis are lectins. So definitely gluten,
maybe dairy but lectins. I would join the chronic disease at autoimmune course. It's
50 bucks to join that course and start working through the videos on that course.
I go into agonizing detail of looking, finding your triggers in an autoimmune disease.
So if you don't find your triggers in your autoimmune disease,
you're not going to get better. So it can be something, like I said,
typically through the throat arthritis, you have to stay with lectins. But there's
very kind of the multiple triggers. So I have people with through the trinity. I stopped
the lectins. I stopped gluten. That really helped me a lot, but I still have these players.
Now you start looking for triggers and putting it on your Sherlock and it's like,
yeah, every time I go outside with high-polyd times, but that is a trigger for me.
So everybody's triggers are going to be different. Remember, every time you have autoantibodies,
that's what any autoimmune disease is. But you have antibodies to self tissue.
You have times to stimulate your immune response. You're going to kill that what you have antibodies
again. So you're going to flare your autoimmune disease when you have any trigger in your body that
stimulates an immune response. So even, you know, chemicals, toxins that you breathe in that
can stimulate an uptick in immune response, you're going to feel worse. So you've got to figure
back out. And you could do tests. You could do antibodies to different chemicals. You could do
antibodies to foods because it can be some weird component in a gluten-free product that you're eating.
You could do antibodies to micro-organisms, biotoxins. You could do tests for those things.
If you have antibodies to ST-MAR, let's say every time you're going to be exposed to that,
again, which is pretty much ubiquitous. It could cause a flare. That could be your trigger.
You've got to figure those out. So highly recommend you take that course.
Just go on a cutters clinic again. Top courses. It's cheap to do. And I give you a ton of
information on how to self-help yourself through those things. You can order labs from the course.
It's highly beneficial. So I'm not pushing it. I just constantly adding new stuff to that course
literally weekly. So any new information that I come up with, I might make a video about it or
slide presentation about or something. You can put it on that course. So do that.